bonsoir et bienvenue pour le 7 8
nouvelle édition ce 3 octobre jusqu'à
19h en direct pour faire le point sur
l'actualité locale ce soir je reçois
tout d'abord Gilles Poutou bonsoir vous
êtes l'administrateur du groupement
géant handicap sur magny-les-hamos
c'était aujourd'hui l'ouverture de la
semaine de l'autonomie à 50 ans en
Yvelines à quoi doit servir cette
semaine ça doit servir à sensibiliser le
plus largement possible au fait que il
faut accompagner prendre en charge le
mieux possible toutes les personnes qui
ont des difficultés en matière
d'autonomie donc essentiellement
personne âgées personne handicapées mais
aussi c'est plus large et c'est un coloc
une semaine pour les professionnels
aujourd'hui il y avait un colloque donc
où on a une succession de d'expertise de
témoignages de table ronde et puis ça
continue demain sur le site même de
géronicap c'est-à-dire un très beau
domaine méronté où il y a un certain
nombre de structures qui qui travaillent
là et puis c'est surtout un lieu
d'échanges de toutes les personnes qui
sont concernées par l'autonomie des
personnes en situation de handicap alors
plus de détails sur cette semaine
justement sur cette question de
l'autonomie dans un instant vous restez
en plateau avec nous à noter également
ce soir nous sommes mercredi c'est la
page culture avec Johanna Soudry bonsoir
Jana bonsoir à tous nous parlerons
ensemble de cinéma cinéma espagnol et de
cirque puisque le cirque itinérant de
Bouglione s'est installé à Plaisir la
page culture à suivre ce soir au cours
de cette édition dans une quinzaine de
minutes et puis juste après la page
culture je recevrai aussi Stanislas
chevalier et les directeurs fondateurs
d'une société yvelinoise corso magenta
il est l'inventeur de la première
peinture qui se pose comme du papier
peint toutes les explications à suivre
ce soir la suite du sommaire de ce 3
octobre c'est en images à présent avec
donc cette deuxième édition de la
Semaine de l'autonomie de Saint-Quentin
en Yvelines qui débute donc la perte
d'autonomie et les moyens pour aider les
personnes on en parlait déjà en 1960
comme on les dispositifs ont évolué
c'était tout l'enjeu d'un colloque qui
s'est déroulé aujourd'hui à notre invité
nous en dire plus
il y a 30 ans Morel Paulette le poète
Louis Aragon figure du surréalisme avec
Elsa Triolet il a longtemps résidé à
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines un
anniversaire relayé par la venue de la
ministre de la Culture Aurélie
philippeetti la directrice adjointe du
site à Saint-Arnoul sera aussi avec nous
sur le plateau ce soir toujours beaucoup
de monde à l'occasion des virades de
l'espoir qui se sont déroulés à
Chevreuse une manifestation qui permet
de collecter des fonds pour la lutte
contre la mucoviscidose reportage à
suivre bouclier en a installé enfin son
chapiteau à Plaisir l'occasion ce soir
de rencontrer la nouvelle garde de ses
professionnels des arts du cirque
cette information aussi à la une de la
presse locale et qui tombe en plan
mondial de l'automobile Peugeot va
freiner la production de la 208 à Poissy
le Parisien Évelyne annonce que
seulement 35 modèles de 208 sortiront de
l'usine yvelinoise chaque jour dès la
semaine prochaine contre 52 actuellement
les intérimaires seront les premiers
touchés 4 à 500 selon les syndicats et
du côté de Renault à Flins cette fois-ci
la situation est également tendue elle
la production de la Zoé et de la Clio 4
qui vont débuter se ferait dans une
situation de sous-effectif ce sont les
syndicats qui le disent à des syndicats
qui se mobilisent une prise de parole
devant l'entreprise et prévu demain à
Flins des syndicats qui souhaitent des
embauches malgré le contexte économique
difficile dans l'automobile les Virades
2 l'espoir permettent chaque année de
récolter des fonds contre la
mucoviscidose et le public répond
toujours présent comme ce week-end Alice
Gastine
pêche aux canards combats de chevaliers
chamboule-tout stand de maquillage les
animations étaient nombreuses ce
week-end au château de la Madeleine
objectif réunir des fonds pour
l'association Vaincre la Mucoviscidose
la maladie génétique la plus importante
en France il y a 2500 malades à peu près
mais comme c'est conseillé comme une
maladie rare l'État ne donne pas
beaucoup la grande horosité de Vaincre
la Mucoviscidose c'est d'avoir monté au
niveau régional pour les malades ce
qu'on appelle des CRCM de centre de
soins spécifiques où il y a des médecins
spécifiques donc quand un gosse est
atteint de muco il va directement s'il
veut là on est venu pour soutenir la
cause d'une part et puis profiter du
beau temps et puis on connaît le château
de la Madeleine donc l'année dernière
c'était sympa mais faisait un temps
abominable et là ça c'est vraiment
étoffé donc c'est très bien très
plaisant et c'est important oui bien sûr
comme comment plus on connaît des gens
qui sont touchés c'est ça nous touche
aussi
et puis c'est à côté de chez nous et
puis il fait beau et puis c'est facile
de venir soutenir en venant passer une
bonne après-midi ici chaque année fin
septembre 400 Virades de l'Espoir sont
organisées à travers la France en 2011
les différentes manifestations
organisées par le collectif de Chevreuse
Saint-Rémy ont permis de récolter 80000
euros pour financer la Recherche et
apporter une aide médicale et financière
aux malades
une semaine pour aborder la question de
l'autonomie entre professionnels le
centre gérondicap à Magny-les-Hameaux
pilote ce rendez-vous qui débute
aujourd'hui Gilles Poutou vous êtes donc
l'administrateur du groupement
géronticap rendez-vous qui est important
pour trouver des solutions à ce problème
de perte d'autonomie on va découvrir
ensemble le chiffre du jour 1,2 millions
il s'affiche et le nombre de
bénéficiaires de l'appât l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie au 31 décembre
2010 ce chiffre un chiffre qui augmente
chaque année est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on
est en mesure de répondre aux réalités
aux difficultés qui se cachent derrière
c'est 1,2 millions de bénéficiaires de
la location
c'est un sujet extrêmement compliqué de
société c'est à dire que nos notre
société vieilli
c'est un mouvement qui s'accélère et ça
pose de multiples problèmes
aujourd'hui une personne sur quatre qui
est plus de 85 ans
est atteinte d'une pathologie de ses
naissances et j'ai une essence cérébrale
c'est un véritable problème sociétal
dont on voit les on est tout début de ce
mouvement là donc aujourd'hui tous les
moyens n'ont pas forcément présents dans
tous les moyens c'est pas forcément
présent parce que on a tendance on a eu
tendance pendant très longtemps à
prendre en compte ce genre de
problématique uniquement par des moyens
alors soit c'est l'hébergement d'accord
donc on parlait avant de maison de
retraite aujourd'hui on parle d'epad et
puis on a médicalisé donc c'est à la
fois l'hébergement et le médical et le
soin or la problématique et aujourd'hui
on peut du tout l'avoir la même façon il
s'agit de d'essayer de conserver
les personnes dans un état d'autonomie à
tous les sens du terme c'est à dire
évidemment en physique mais aussi
mentale mais aussi
culturel social etc le plus longtemps
possible le plus possible jusque aux
limites du possible en tout cas et
nos structures s'adaptent tout doucement
mais elles sont pas parfaitement
aujourd'hui adaptées
c'est pas parce que on a 80 ans qu'on
est 90 ans c'est pas parce qu'on est un
handicap quel qu'il soit une pathologie
qui est dégénérative c'est pas pour ça
que on doit automatiquement perdre la
possibilité de se réaliser dans la
société c'est pas pour ça qu'on doit
être institutionnalisé on doit pouvoir
acheter chez soi etc c'est toutes ces
problématiques là qu'on aborde donc on a
abordé aujourd'hui la semaine de
l'autonomie a débuté aujourd'hui dès ce
matin par un colloque nos équipes
étaient présentes reportage de Patrick
Jacques de nismud et Catherine zulator
deuxième édition d'un colloque pour
parler de l'autonomie les premières lois
sur la prise en charge de la perte
d'autonomie en France date de 1962 avec
l'instauration des aides à domicile 50
ans plus tard quel bilan dressé et bien
cet université n'a pas la langue de bois
effectivement il y a ce rapport larogue
de 62 qui dit les gens veulent rester
chez eux faut les aider et la Cour des
comptes en 2005 disait grosso modo en 40
ans on a fait des choses mais aucun
gouvernement quel qu'il soit n'a été
jusqu'au bout le courage c'est mettre un
peu plus d'argent notamment sur les
services à domicile on sait que les gens
veulent rester chez eux donc on sait
aujourd'hui que l'essentiel du travail
est fait par les familles beaucoup trop
Bernard ennuyer pointe également du
doigt les manques de cohérence entre les
différents dispositifs à 50 ans en
Yvelines exemple pourrait venir de
gérondicap un groupement de coopération
qui intervient dans le domaine de la
gérontologie et du handicap c'est lui
qui est à l'origine de ce colloque ça va
dans la bonne direction bien plus que
dans d'autres départements donc je peux
dire que je vais initi avec plaisir la
perte d'autonomie ne se limite pas aux
personnes âgées des salariés peuvent
également être concernés autre exemple
de mise en commun le réseau Yvelines
santé travail nous avons des équipes qui
sont des équipes pluridisciplinaires
puisque souvent il y a plusieurs ou
causes ou surtout plusieurs types de
problèmes il y a un ergonome il y a une
juriste psychologue et une assistante
sociale nous appliquons une méthodologie
qui est reconnue nationalement cette
année Yvelines Santé Travail à traiter
600 dossiers et 80% des salariés ont été
maintenus en emploi en matière de perte
d'autonomie le meilleur conseil est de
prendre contact avec la coordination
gérontologique de son territoire un
projet de loi sur cette question
pourrait être présenté en 2014 par la
ministre de la Santé
dans ce sujet on a entendu au tout début
du sujet que les premières lois sur la
prise en charge de l'autonomie en France
remonte en 1962 les années 60 on a le
sentiment que les choses n'ont pas
avancé très très vite le rapport Laroque
auquel fait allusion Bernard ennuyer
dans l'interview c'est 1962 alors c'est
pas une loi c'est un rapport mais qui
pointe de manière assez
large assez complète les problématiques
c'est à dire la société vieilli on va
avoir de plus en plus de questions qui
vont tenir à l'accompagnement comment on
fait pour qu'une personne quelle que
soit sa maladie quel que soit son
handicap son infirmité comment faire
pour qu'elle reste le plus possible
socialisé quelle est comment dire la
capacité de d'agir selon ses propres
valeurs vous voyez c'est tout l'inverse
de l'assistance il a fallu 50 ans pour
que véritablement aujourd'hui les choses
commencent à se mettre en place comment
seulement parce qu'on parle donc d'une
réforme aussi de la dépendance prévue
pour 2014 il va falloir encore attendre
un petit peu même alors on peut pas dire
que rien ne s'est fait bon il y a plein
de choses qui sont faites
parler de dans le reportage de de
coordination gérontologique locale on
pourrait parler de réseau de santé pour
les personnes âgées on pourrait parler
de la multiplication des services à
domicile il y a plein de choses qui
existent si vous l'aimez on est à une
phase si vous voulez ou on a fait plein
de petites choses et aujourd'hui le
problème c'est d'arriver à relier tout
ça c'est à dire faire que des
microsystèmes puissent donner lieu à
quelque chose qui soit beaucoup plus
large que ce soit naturel et automatique
si vous l'avez toutes les compétences
qu'on a accumulées pour que les
personnes qui sont en perte d'autonomie
puissent vivre correctement normalement
comme il se doit pour être obligé la
réforme de la dépendance pour 2014 au
mieux parce que ça va dépendre aussi des
finances publiques et une réforme qui
serait portée par Michel Delaunay la
ministre donc déléguée aux personnes
âgées à l'autonomie elle devait
d'ailleurs être présentes ce matin pour
l'ouverture de la semaine de l'autonomie
à Saint-Quentin c'est pas le cas c'était
pas là vous le regrettez
bien sûr bon on avait on savait que le
le gouvernement est actuellement en
train de définir un certain nombre de
choses le monde de la santé est
compliqué le monde de l'autonomie aussi
donc on savait que ils sont en train de
préparer effectivement un certain nombre
de projets dont le fameux projet qui
aboutira peut-être à ce qui est une loi
en 2014 donc bon on a vu des indications
comme quoi il était pas certain que
madame de l'olivienne alors évidemment
on le regrette alors c'est pas qu'on le
regrette parce que c'est gérondicat et
qu'on aurait aimé qui est la ministre
c'est toujours bien qui est le ministre
mais c'est surtout parce que on a
vraiment conçu nous ces journées enfin
toute cette semaine pour vraiment faire
remonter les préoccupations
concrets de tous les jours quoi à la
fois des personnes elles-mêmes qui sont
perd d'autonomie mais aussi de tous les
aidants qui soient que ce soit disait
dans naturelle si vous voulez familier
ou proche ou que ce soit les personnes
qui travaillent dans ces différentes
structures d'aide à domicile des pads
d'hôpitaux etc
aujourd'hui il y a des choses
extrêmement concrètes à mettre en oeuvre
c'est-à-dire ce qu'on attend aujourd'hui
des pouvoirs publics c'est que on aide
pas forcément avec des folle si vous
voulez mais simplement qu'on puisse
aider les structures qui disent
aujourd'hui à trouver une synergie
commune et un projet commun que ça
puisse s'encrer dans le territoire si
vous voulez alors tout le monde a cette
envie là mais le problème c'est que
souvent les plans qui sont faits si vous
voulez année après année gouvernement
après gouvernement mais ça tombe du haut
alors je suis en train de dire que le
gouvernement écoute pas les les gens qui
travaillent à la base si vous voulez
mais le problème c'est qu'ils en
écoutent certains et donc du coup on a
souvent le sentiment que il y a des
plans qui tombent comme ça parce qu'on a
écouté telouté l'expert très bien mais
aujourd'hui le problème il est pas là
par exemple exemple de gérant vous allez
nous dire pourquoi c'est un exemple
juste après cette question du jour nous
sommes allés voir les les cinq
continents avec cette question les
dispositifs d'accompagnement qui
existent à l'heure actuelle sont il
suffisants à votre avis
je pense aux transports publics quibus
qui sont pas du tout très bien équipés
pour les handicapés là-dessus il y a
beaucoup de choses encore à faire oui
bien sûr
je pense que oui ça citation c'est je
pense que ceux qui sont à perdre
d'autonomie d'avoir beaucoup de
difficultés à prendre les transports
aussi beaucoup d'immeubles sont encore
avec des escaliers
et pas de rampe d'accès ou pas
d'ascenseur non je pense pas enfin dans
certaines gares par exemple c'est le cas
le plus
dans les gars c'est là où on est le plus
souvent et c'est vrai que des fois il y
a pas de rampe d'accès il y a des
escaliers voilà je pense que on doit
encore faire plus d'efforts moi j'habite
à Saint-Quentin et moi je trouve que
c'est passé on fait juste un tour au
niveau du centre commercial de Carrefour
je trouve que c'est pas adapté pour des
personnes handicapées je trouve ça
malheureux sinon au niveau des parkings
des places de parking je trouve qu'ils
ont fait un grand effort mais au niveau
des commerces je trouve que c'est pas
assez alors moi je pense qu'il faut
vraiment mettre le paquet parce qu'il
n'y aura que des vieux bientôt donc non
vraiment il faut renforcer ces
dispositifs plus de formation pour que
les personnes qui se trouvent à mobilité
réduite ou handicapés que ce soit par
l'âge ou par la maladie ou n'importe
quoi puisse vraiment compter sur un
réseau efficace
les gens qui ont évoqué aussi notamment
les problèmes au quotidien les problèmes
de transport des choses des choses qui
qu'elles rencontrent les difficultés
quotidiennes mais on parlait
véritablement aussi des dispositifs
d'accompagnement de la nécessité de les
mettre en place des exemples qui peuvent
servir pour le gouvernement pourquoi pas
pour la réforme de la dépendance un
exemple c'est gérant handicap donc vous
pilotez le groupement géant handicap sur
Manille et à moi ou quoi c'est un
exemple ça peut servir de modèle
absolument alors j'ai rendu cap c'est
quoi c'est une histoire qui consiste à
se dire sur une communauté d'agglo comme
50 ans en Yvelines c'est une population
il y a 25 ans c'est une population jeune
cette population elle vieillit et donc
ça peut poser des problèmes multiformes
alors on a vu le type de problème qui
sent dans les interviews ou là
effectivement tout ce qui est mobilité
déplacement etc c'est une question c'est
une question très importante alors
l'autre aspect si vous voulez ce que
qu'on a essayé de de développer dans le
cadre de géronica c'est comment
permettre à des personnes qui sont des
difficultés avec pour rester autonome
complètement comment faire pour que y
ait une prise en charge charge la plus
globale possible alors ça veut dire dans
un premier temps tout faire pour que la
personne puisse rester à domicile quand
tu es dans son domicile on est chez soi
et donc c'est là où on a la probablement
la meilleure capacité à agir selon ses
valeurs ses croyances etc quel que soit
les problèmes de santé qu'on peut avoir
donc j'ai handicap c'est quoi c'est
essayer de structurer de coordonner tous
les acteurs qui peuvent concourir à ça
alors c'est pour ça que Jérôme handicap
il y a une association qui s'appelle
amadom et qui cherche à améliorer
professionnaliser tout ce que vous
voulez tout ce qui est service de
domicile ce qu'on appelait avant les
aides ménagères les femmes de ménage
aujourd'hui on appelle on les appelle
les auxiliaires de vie sociale c'est
beaucoup plus ça d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
c'est un métier qui est différent mais
qui est important parce que c'est
souvent le premier contact vous voyez
pour la personne fragilisée ou la
personne âgée et c'est aussi important
au quotidien que le médecin qui
évidemment tous à son rôle c'est aussi
important que la structure
par exemple l'épisode hospitalier où
tout autre structure si vous voulez
médicaliser ou en tout cas où il y a un
certain nombre de paramédicaux donc ce
qu'on a voulu faire c'est faire que tous
ces experts c'est de de la de service
d'aide à domicile jusque au médecin les
plus qualifiés en passant par toute les
paramédicaux que ce soit les
angothérapeutes les infirmières les
kinés etc
tout est professions qui concourent à
l'autonomie essayer de développer un
projet commun valable pour l'ensemble du
territoire et qui semble plutôt bien
fonctionner pour l'instant on a eu
l'occasion d'en parler plusieurs fois
sur ce plateau merci d'être venu la
semaine de l'autonomie à Saint-Quentin
qui se poursuit donc encore c'est
jusqu'au 5 octobre le mercredi nous nous
intéressons aussi à la culture avec
Johanna Soudry qui va me rejoindre pour
sa chronique hebdomadaire